so
one uh question i have it's a difficult
one
uh so i talk about love a lot
and you've just talked about donald
trump i guarantee you though this
particular segment would be full of
division from
the internet yes but i
believe that should be and can be fixed
what i'm referring to in particular is
the division
because we've talked about the value of
reason
and what i've noticed on the internet is
the division
shuts down reason so when people hear
you say trump actually the first
sentence you said about trump
they'll hear trump and their ears will
perk up and they'll immediately start in
that first sentence they'll say
is he a trump supporter or a trust
they're not interested in anything else
after that and then after that
that's it and what how do so my question
is
you as one of the beacons of
intellectualism
quite honest i mean it sounds silly to
say but
you are a beacon of reason how do we
bring people together
long enough to where we can reason
i mean there's no easy way out of this
because
the fact that people have become tribal
and they have very tribal
uh and the tribe uh
in the tribe reason doesn't matter and
it's all about emotion
it's all about belonging and not
belonging and you don't want to stand
out
you don't want to have a different
opinion you want to belong
and it's all about belonging it took us
decades to get back
to tribalism where we were hundreds of
years ago
it took millennium to get out of
tribalism it took the enlightenment
to get us to the point of individualism
where we think for in reason respect for
reason
before that we were all tribal so it
took the enlightenment to get us out of
it
we've been in the enlightenment for
about 250 years influenced by the
enlightenment
and we're and it's fading the impact is
fading
so what would we need to get out of it
we need self-esteem
people join a tribe because they don't
trust their own mind
people join a tribe because they're
afraid to stand on their own two feet
they're afraid to think for themselves
they're afraid to be different they're
afraid to be unique they're afraid to be
an individual
people need self-esteem to gain
self-esteem
they have to they have to have respect
for rationality
they have to think and they have to
achieve and they have to recognize that
achievement
to do that they have to be
they have to have respect for thinking
they have to have to respect for reason
uh and we have to and and think about
the schools we have to have schools that
teach people to think
teach people to to value their mind we
have schools that teach people to
feel and value their feelings we have
groups of six-year-olds sitting around a
circle
discussing politics what they don't know
anything
they're ignorant so you don't know
anything when you're ignorant
yes you can feel but your feelings are
useless
as as decision making tools but but we
emphasize emotion
it's all about socialization and emotion
this is why
they talk about this generation of
snowflakes they can't hear anything that
that they're opposed to
because they've not learned how to use
their mind how to think
so it boils down to teaching people how
to think two things
how to think and how to care about
themselves
so it's it's thinking of self-esteem and
they're connected
because when you think you achieve which
gains you
gains your self-esteem when you have
self-esteem it's easier to think for
yourself
and i don't know how you do that quickly
i mean
i think leadership matters so you know
part of what i try to do
is try to encourage people to do those
things but
i am a small voice
you